IN ONE PIECE.
BRET?
>> Bret: LUCAS TOMLINSON.
LUCAS, THANK YOU.
SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS ON OUR TOP
STORIES, LET'S BRING IN SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST BRIT HUME.
I WANT TO START WITH IMPEACHMENT
AND WHERE WE STAND TONIGHT.
AS TIME GOES ON AND WE GO INTO A
CHRISTMAS BREAK AND BREAKING FOR
THE NEW YEAR, DO YOU THINK MORE
TIME HELPS DEMOCRATS MAKE THAT
CASE FOR MORE WITNESSES AND
DOCUMENTS IN THE SENATE TRIAL?
>> I'M NOT SURE THIS CURRENT
WEEK, THIS HOLIDAY WEEK FOR THE
NEW YEAR WILL MAKE MUCH
DIFFERENCE, BUT EVERYTHING WE
ARE SEEING FROM SENATOR SCHUMER
AND SPEAKER PELOSI SUGGESTS THAT
THEY ARE IN REAL DOUBT AS TO
WHETHER THE EVIDENCE THAT
THEY'VE BROUGHT FORTH SO FAR IS
GOOD ENOUGH AND THEY ARE VERY,
VERY URGENTLY SEEKING A WAY TO
HOPEFULLY FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE
FIND SOME MORE EVIDENCE BUT
THAT'S WHAT THIS WHOLE ISSUE
ABOUT TRYING TO BRING IN
WITNESSES, THERE CERTAINLY
WEREN'T ANY WITNESSES IN THE
CLINTON IMPEACHMENT.
IT ALL SEEMS TO BE ABOUT LITA
McCONNELL IN THE SENATE
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHT
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHE
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHC
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHR
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHE
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHT
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHS
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHA
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHI
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHN
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITH,
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHI
MEETING SEEMS COME TO BALL WITHT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE IN A HURRY
TO START THE TRIAL AND SPEAKER
PELOSI DOES NOT HAVE ANY
LEVERAGE OVER HIM AND THE
CONSTITUTION DOESN'T GIVE HER
AND THE AND THE ONLY WAY TO MAKE
THIS WORK IS PUBLIC PRESSURE TO
DEMAND WITNESSES.
McCONNELL HAS THE VOTES.
HE COULD RUN THIS TRIAL ANYWAY
HE WANTS TO.
>> Bret: BRIT, DO YOU GET THE
SENSE ON THE UKRAINE ISSUE BUT
WITH HIS NEW TALK ABOUT POSSIBLY
LOOKING BACK AT THE MUELLER
REPORT AND THE DOCUMENTS THAT
THE HOUSE WAS TRYING TO GET FROM
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO FIND
SOMETHING EVEN WITH MORE TIME TO
MAYBE EVEN STICK THAT INTO AN
IMPEACHMENT ARTICLE?
>> THAT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT ALL OF IT ADDS UP TO THE
SAME THING THOUGH, BRET, THAT
WHAT THEY HAVE SO FAR ISN'T
ENOUGH AND SO FAR THEY HAVE
UTTERLY FAILED TO MOVE A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN VOTE EITHER IN THE
HOUSE OR THE SENATE, AT LEAST
THAT WE KNOW OF.
NO SENATOR HAS COME FORWARD TO
SAY THAT HE OR SHE IS IN FAVOR
OF VOTING TO CONVICT THE
PRESIDENT.
IT IS A VERY HIGH BAR, REQUIRING
TWO-THIRDS OF THE SENATE.
NO INDICATION IT'S GOING TO GET
ANYWHERE NEAR THAT.
AND I SERIOUSLY DOUBT, BRET, IF
THEY WOULD WHOMP UP FURTHER
CHARGES BASED ON THE MUELLER
REPORT WHICH LARGELY EXONERATED
THE PRESIDENT.
IT RAISED UP SOME OBJECTION OF
JUSTICE ISSUES BUT IT WAS NOT
ENOUGH FOR MUELLER ESSAY THAT IT
WAS OBJECTION OF JUSTICE.
THAT WAS REJECTED BY ROD
ROSENSTEIN AND OF COURSE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING IS
AN EXTREME LONG SHOT AND MAYBE
TWO LONG SHOTS.
>> Bret: AS WE GET TO THE END
OF THE YEAR, THE PRESIDENT
SEEMED LIKE HE HAS SOME
POLITICAL WIND TO HIS BACK
DESPITE THE IMPEACHMENT.
HE'S PULLING
THE ECONOMY IS CHURNING ON ALL
CYLINDERS.
>> IS NORMALLY THE MOST CRITICAL
ISSUE.
WHAT'S GIVING HIM BRILLIANCY
THEPOSSIBILITY WE MIGHT BE LOOKI
THEPOSSIBILITY WE MIGHT BE LOOKG
AT THE ONSET OF A RECESSION
BEFORE THE 2020 ELECTION BUT
NOBODY SEEMS TO BE SAYING THAT.
IF YOU ARE IN THE INVESTOR, YOU
THINK THAT'S A PAIN, WHEN THE
BODY IS WORRIED.
A POLITICAL STANDPOINT, THE
PRESIDENT APPEARS TO BE IN
BETTER SHAPE THAN HE WAS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR WHICH IS
HARDLY WHAT THE ADVERSARIES IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WOULD HOPE
FOR WHEN THEY WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO IMPEACH
HIM.
THAT'S THE WAY THE MATTERS
STANDS FOR NOW AT LEAST HOW I
SEE IT.
>> Bret: LAST THING, DO YOU
EXPECT NANCY PELOSI TO MOVE
THESE ARTICLES SOON AFTER WE GET
BACK FROM THIS BREAK,
JANUARY 6TH, 7TH?
THAT STANDOFF IS GOING TO STOP?
>> I WOULD THINK SO BECAUSE I
THINK SHE MADE A STAND HERE IN
TRYING TO FIGURE A WAY TO GET
SOME MORE EVIDENCE INTO THE
CASE.
IF THAT FAILS, IF SHE JUST
LEAVES THE ARTICLES IN THE HOUSE
AND NEVER MOVES TO THE SENATE,
THE WHOLE THING KIND OF DIES.
ALTERNATIVELY PERHAPS
McCONNELL WOULD HAVE THE
OPTION OF MAKING A MOTION IN THE
SENATE TO DISMISS THE CASE FOR
LACK OF PROSECUTION.